Hey ladies and gentlemen I'm Ilana I
work for a company called fun house and
we did a drunk stream where we took a
drink of white cloth every time we like
failed in Super Mario maker 2 or
whatever which I'm very bad at I thought
I would continue the party at home for
all of you I don't have any white claw
but I do have truly and Sakura shadows
died last [ __ ]
that's pear en bloc that's attack
that's LTE is Apple these [ __ ] in
here have like fire and [ __ ] look at
that guy look at him this is not gonna
be easy because I don't remember how to
play this game that's the real issue the
alcohol is actually not that much of a
problem it's everything else your your
uh us oh you can climb dad she says
shocked that the several armed creature
can't nope nope no you don't wanna do
that [ __ ] oh are you kidding I just I
thought I was gonna grab a drink
whoa he's right there oh [ __ ]
Alana Alana Oh water just start good
I actually finished the can this part
should be easy I know there's just some
little wolf [ __ ] down here can you
run no just sneak I don't know how to
play this game come on not want to use
there we go oh I missed it I was so
stoked as I counts on me I'll deflect
you it'll be great and I missed it both
times what do you take your wolf what
are you worried about thank you I
thought what you're supposed to be tough
and that canines more like Conte nines
know what we need to jump away from that
get away all right we got it
dead rekt jump don't let these fire boys
ruin your day Ilana
yes coins yes yes good yes oh oh oh that
was an unblockable attack he did from
the ledge below me what a dick monk more
like punk okay it should I could fight
the monkeys just for shits and giggles
out actually I shouldn't I shouldn't
have
I should not just for shoot some geek
she said well okay this one is
pomegranate it tastes like alcohol good
did used to make me but I'm gonna regret
making this video okay bye
two suitors game don't have a sprint
button what happens if I tap a
repeatedly like in GTA
what's this seizure you have going on
here so what is what is this some
maneuver my dude
they have just no posture they just are
you just worn out from all that throwing
and you've been doing
did I use both my healing go it's
already problem with playing this drunk
is that you don't remember what you've
already done I hate this bit though
no not that's it there we go we need to
get loaded axe out cuz there's [ __ ]
these little [ __ ] loads with their
stupid hats I don't I don't like them I
don't really want anything to do with
you you suck to fight and I would prefer
the bugs Rick Lee but alright mate sick
rolled oh [ __ ] me oh you're a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] he's seen me he has seen
me haha yeah mm-hmm okay it's like that
but hit me before it even happened you
just flipped away what's the plan mate
all right yeah you trying to impress me
but I am wet there's another one
[ __ ] me what happened who what who did
that there's two more of them [ __ ] this
place I know I'm not I don't think I
should even try to do this fight while
I'm drunk
I don't think it's gonna turn out well
for me I feel like I could just come
back here at some on the point in time
because right now oh oh I didn't even
see him [ __ ]
I actually like fighting you thanks for
asking cuz we can do that over and over
and over again boom too many of them at
once probably that same knot you lizard
don't you [ __ ] sneak up on me you
little punk that's it
cool yeah jump into the monks you're a
great shinobi Pierce look at you just
out of nowhere no one ever sees you
coming this I'm gonna die real quick
though okay I needed that that was
alright [ __ ] [ __ ] they're real false
monks I thought you guys were supposed
to like take naps real amigo something
he's got a board I don't want to [ __ ]
with that that's you that should be
illegal what are you gonna do I don't
think that's gonna end well for you I'm
pretty cool pretty sure you can't do
[ __ ] but if you could forget about me
that would be cool
and I'm not talking to the video game
just everyone in general for that one
just if you could just forget I existed
life would be a lot easier I think I got
too real you know something that I
realized recently it's good existential
only unlike the lost you who's that
thousands of versions of me or you
anyone really exists and and some of
them are completely wrong nonsense I see
people on the internet lie about me all
the time right and other people just
believe it don't even question it and I
don't go in there and correct it because
I don't want to do that but I really
realized that recently right people
people say they know who you are based
on like one comment sometimes that
someone else is made that isn't even
true
your boys dead and basically they just
think that you're this person think it
was completely not and here's the thing
that I learned recently it's not your
job to fix that people are allowed to
have their complete and other
misconceptions about you if you were to
dedicate your life to trying to fix them
that would be thousands of conceptions
that you have to try to fix you can't
you just gotta let people think whatever
they think and let that version of you
that you know isn't actually you exist
in their heads because it would
literally be a non-stop full-time job
for you to try to dedicate your life to
correcting the way that people see you
start with it well where are you mate
I'm down for a ruckus if you would there
you are [ __ ]
the hardest part of this fall drunk is
stealth my situational awareness is
Blackey good and everybody is killing me
that's they just ace they're all stealth
in me is what's happening here ooh
Oh who are you
hello oh you are handsome but I am ish
scared of you okay oh there are three of
the same guy right here I don't remember
how to do the move where you used to oh
my god oh my god that many flips should
be illegal those too many no didn't like
that
do you think they're having a meeting
like what do you think they're talking
about the monkeys probably just dancin
haven't I press B I press B I'm pressing
B repeatedly and it's not working
so all this tool we're out here and
it'll hit her tits I am much too squish
not the character that's me I've gained
a lot of weight this year these dudes
are deaf so who gives a [ __ ]
creep up on this [ __ ] up ease up now no
idea oh you didn't see that comment they
do a big boy do I have anything that I
just give me like a tiny bit out sure no
actually I don't eat it I need to pee
is it always okay these [ __ ] I
don't like him okay well sure we'll
finally one of them seen me that seems
like oh well no more now did he lose me
because he ran inside of a building
acted to pee I need to pee take care of
that one step at a time boys
do you have it eat just like a whole
last boiled egg oh you don't know I
would never do that either
I just conversational no I totally have
sex protein tastes like farts what are
they doing in that house do you think
oh my god please separate yourselves
that would be like the hottest thing
I've ever seen holy [ __ ] are you
separating yourselves yes that's so
[ __ ] hot well until that happens I
still got one though oh that's tight
here's how you play a stealth game
ladies gentlemen you just hide around
this here corner until somebody comes to
you and you hope it's just one of them
oh why does he have that much range
oh no I'm bailing I'm bailing [ __ ]
[ __ ] dicks oh these guys are pricks I
think I fought them before though where
did it get harder
I got my stealth back do you think them
having more alcohol is helping cuz it
seems like that's what's happening cool
cool cool cool cool tight tight tight
tight tight is this guy facing me do you
think that I can sneak up - want to kill
him without the only noticing me no he's
facing me yeah now he is I think I have
fought one of these before I just forgot
about it
maybe he's blocking me a lot though his
postures real good it's a lot of posture
for a guy wearing a [ __ ] potato sack
and he's I have to fight three of these
oh you [ __ ] I'm not taking that no [ __ ]
Oh hit B but it was too late why did you
unlock from him
no no I'm locked again this game does
that a lot huh [ __ ] me [ __ ] me great
okay well
I feel like I should probably call it um
thank you for joining me
drunk Sakura McDonald's you know